ALEX DANILO: When you're
developing for Google Cast,
you have to realize it's a true
multiscreen experience, where
you have a phone or tablet
in your hand connected
to a big, beautiful
TV in the living room.
Now, I can choose a
video to play on my phone
and send it to the Cast device.
How good is that?
Hold on a sec.
Now while playing,
I might choose
to put my phone in my
pocket or walk away.
And if I walk out
of Wi-Fi range,
I'll loose connection
with the Cast device.
But the video should keep
playing because I haven't
intentionally disconnected.
[VIDEO PLAYING]
Now that I've finished
with that treatment,
I might decide to go back to my
movie and start watching again.
If I walk back into Wi-Fi
range, the app on my phone
should connect automatically.
We call that reconnection logic.
It's really important
for a good experience
that your user feels in
control, and reconnection logic
is core to that principle.
So that's something to remember.
MALE SPEAKER: Excuse me,
we're trying work here.
Would you mind keeping it down?
ALEX DANILO: Whilst
connected, I might
choose to disconnect
from the Cast device
and continue
watching on my phone.
Now if I disconnect, what
should happen on the big TV
is that since no one's
connected to the Cast device,
the video should stop playing.
But, on the other hand, we
do have the shared model
where you can have one
or many people connected
to the Cast device.
So for example, if
I'm watching YouTube,
I can Cast content to my TV set.
And then my kid
decides they want
something else in
the playlist, they
can connect to add
their selection.
If I then disconnect
from the cast device,
the video should keep playing
because my kid is still
connected to the Cast device.
We call that
multisyndicapability.
Looking at it another way, to
avoid the Cast device playing
back without anyone
in control, you
should always ensure
at least one user
is connected to the Cast device.
Adhering to these UX
guidelines will give your users
a beautiful experience
that will appear magical.
Not only that, but if you
do everything by the book,
we might even feature your app.
And that's pretty cool.
[MUSIC PLAYING]